[Música]
30 años después del conocido en Londres
como el miércoles negro la libra volvió
a experimentar unas jornadas de máxima
tensión si el 17 de septiembre de 1992
El mismísimo Banco Central de Inglaterra
tuvo que sucumbir ante el asalto
financiero capitaneado por George soros
y en esta ocasión fue el propio gobierno
británico quien desató la tormenta el
día 23 de septiembre del 2022 dio
comienzo una rocambolesca historia que
terminó con una reprimenda del fmi una
salida masiva de inversores y una
intervención de emergencia del Banco
Central para tratar de contener el caos
según Larry Summers el Reino Unido
podría desencadenar una crisis global a
medida que la libera se derrumba
mientras los rendimientos de los bonos
se disparan en poco tiempo la
incertidumbre las dudas el miedo y los
peores augurios rodearon la economía
británica y de hecho en menos de un año
el tipo de interés exigido por el
mercado para la deuda pública del Reino
Unido se ha llegado a multiplicar por 10
tal y como podéis ver si a finales del
2021 el gobierno británico podía emitir
bonos a dos años pagando poco más del
0,4%, tras la crisis equilibrar los
tipos exigidos superan el 4
[Música]
Y para colmo podemos encontrarnos
noticias como esta goldman sacks
advierte que la inflación en Reino Unido
podría superar el 22% el próximo año y
la pregunta es Pero qué día antes está
pasando en Londres Por qué la libra se
está desplomando cómo se explica que el
coste de la deuda británica haya
superado al de países como Grecia España
o Italia y la pregunta más importante de
todas qué demonios han hecho en el 10 de
Downey Street para desatar semejante
tormenta queridos amigos amigas En este
vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes tenemos que
saber dónde nos encontramos exactamente
arranquemos
[Música]
pero un minuto antes de continuar porque
te quiero hacer una pregunta te gusta lo
que hacemos Te gustaría contribuir a que
este proyecto siga creciendo y mejorando
y al mismo tiempo recibir algunos
beneficios exclusivos Como por ejemplo
nuestro famoso boletín o regalos únicos
Pues si es así te invitamos a que te
sumes a nuestra comunidad de patrón nos
ayudarás a llegar mucho más lejos y
podremos recorrer ese camino Juntos por
ejemplo Gracias a todos los que ya nos
apoyéis en esta comunidad en 2022 hemos
podido lanzar nuestro canal hermano de
economía visual economic y ya os
adelanto que estamos preparando muchas
más cosas os dejamos toda la info en la
descripción dicho esto continuamos
[Música]
Reino Unido tiene un serio problema
desde la crisis financiera del 2008 su
economía no ha vuelto a ser la misma el
último ejemplo como podéis ver se
convirtió en el único miembro del g7
cuya economía seguía siendo A mediados
del 2022 más pequeña que antes de la
pandemia incluso la recuperación de un
país como Italia fue más fuerte pero
amigos amigas esto es tan solo la punta
del iceberg
desde la crisis financiera el pib Per
cápita Real del Reino Unido Apenas ha
crecido y se ha quedado muy por detrás
de países como Estados Unidos o Alemania
Hablamos de una diferencia de casi 10
puntos esta falta de crecimiento menos
de un 4% en 14 años hizo que los
servicios públicos tuvieran que
financiarse cada vez más con deuda y
también con la mayor presión fiscal de
los últimos 40 años en el país
[Música]
y de Quién fue la culpa de la
productividad para que os hagáis una
idea entre el año 2008 y el 2020 la
productividad laboral en el Reino Unido
apenas creció un 0,4% anual esto es
menos de la mitad que el promedio de la
ocd en dinero con tantitonante esto
supuso que respecto a países como
Francia o Alemania los británicos
dejarán de ganar 4000 $ por persona y
claro eso se nota y la pregunta es Y por
qué demonios crece tan poco la
productividad británica
[Música]
pues entre otras cosas porque en este
país la inversión empresarial esto es la
inversión en máquinas fábricas
ordenadores centros de trabajo etcétera
etcétera se encuentra por los suelos no
me creéis pues fijaos
[Música]
es la más baja de todos los países del
g7
[Música]
la hiper especialización financiera y la
incertidumbre causada por el brexit han
tenido mucho que ver en este mal
desempeño que además ha tenido otras
consecuencias por ejemplo esta
hiperespecialización financiera la falta
de inversión y la mala evolución de la
productividad han hecho que el Reino
Unido sea cada vez más dependiente del
exterior lo que ha provocado que el
déficit por cuenta corriente supere el
8% fundamentalmente como consecuencia
del Fuerte déficit comercial esto es de
que las importaciones superen con mucho
las exportaciones
[Música]
a ver un momento esto no tiene que ser
estrictamente malo siempre y cuando las
exportaciones financieras sean capaces
de compensarlo y si no que se lo digan a
Estados Unidos El problema es que para
que esto se produzca tienes que tener la
confianza de los inversores del resto
del mundo para que sigan comprando
libras porque si no es así entonces sí
que te puedes meter de lleno en una
descomunal crisis Claro que esta no es
la única consecuencia de la infra
inversión y la mala evolución de la
productividad otra consecuencia mucho
más visible tiene que ver precisamente
con los salarios fijaos
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea si en 2007
los salarios británicos una vez
descontada la inflación era más altos
que los de Francia o Alemania hoy ya son
más bajos Por qué Pues porque entre los
años 2010 y 2019 no crecieron
prácticamente nada además los hogares
británicos de bajos ingresos también son
mucho más pobres concretamente un 22% y
un 21% más pobres que los franceses y
los alemanes respectivamente
Y para colmo la deuda pública como
porcentaje del pib ha abatido su máximo
nivel desde 1960 Así que como veis la
economía británica ni atraviesa su mejor
momento ni es lo que conoceríamos como
boyante los últimos años han sido más
bien malos pero un momento por cara la
nueva primera ministra la sustituta de
Boris Johnson Tiene un plan un mega plan
que supuesto dar todo un carpetazo en la
mesa atentos
[Música]
el plan
tan solo dos semanas después de hacerse
con las riendas del 10 de Down Street y
luego el gobierno de listras de un golpe
en la mesa y presentó un programa
económico que rompe por completo con lo
que ha sido la política del partido
conservador durante la última década
pistas junto a su canciller del tesoro
cuasi worten han diseñado una bomba de
recortes de impuestos supresión de
regulaciones Y gasto público para
reactivar la economía británica todo un
chute de pinefrina para hacer volver a
latir el corazón económico del país
según la propia primera ministra el
objetivo fundamental de este plan es
acabar de cuajo con las políticas de la
redistribución para centrarse por
completo la producción y la
productividad es decir dejar de pensar
en cómo repartir la pasta para volver a
pensar en cómo crearla de nuevo Lo que
era completamente insostenible era esta
idea de que simplemente podíamos grabar
Nuestro camino hacia la prosperidad y
olvidar el hecho de que habíamos
alcanzado un máximo de impuestos en 70
años donde queríamos que terminara eso
cusi worten canciller del tesoro y ojo
que no estamos ante una improvisación ni
un plan diseñado en el último minuto
para nada en 2012 tanto listas como
corte fueron coautores de un libro donde
ya desglosaban muchas de Estas ideas y
claro ahora que se han hecho con el
poder pues han tenido la oportunidad de
sacar su plan adelante ahora bien En qué
consiste exactamente esta supuesta
vuelta con muchos matices a la era de
sacher Pues veréis por un lado el
gobierno ha hecho pública su intención
de llevar a cabo el mayor recorte de
impuestos desde 1972
esto incluye un montón de medidas como
la reversión del aumento del impuesto
sobre beneficios para dejarlo en el
19%. la reducción en un punto del
impuesto de la renta para todos los
contribuyentes la reducción de los
impuestos sobre el capital la reducción
de las cotizaciones al seguro la
congelación de los impuestos especiales
e incluso inicialmente porque luego como
veremos lo han tenido que suspender las
reducción en 5 puntos del tramo más alto
del impuesto de la renta es decir ningún
cambio radical pero sí Muchos pequeños
cambios que junto supondrán el mayor
recortar impuestos llevado a cabo por un
gobierno británico en las últimas cinco
décadas
pero no no todo va de impuestos
[Música]
el nuevo gobierno también se ha
comprometido a meter la tijera la
regulaciones algo que por ejemplo ya han
comenzado a hacer al suspender los
límites legales que existían sobre los
bonus del sector financiero algo que fue
establecido por la Unión Europea en el
año 2004 Y esto es tan solo el principio
acogemos con satisfacción la Clara
dirección y el nuevo enfoque de
alcanciller y su fuerte respaldo al
sector de los servicios financieros como
el catalizador de la economía del Reino
Unido las medidas anunciadas hoy son el
comienzo de lo que se necesita para
liberar toda la fuerza del sector
comunicado de yucate finance la patronal
financiera del Reino Unido Asimismo
también han anunciado la creación de
numerosas zonas económicas especiales a
lo largo y ancho de todo el país zonas
que contarán con algunas ventajas
Fiscales y regulatorias y cuyo objetivo
número uno será hacer crecer la
inversión empresarial es algo así como
una evolución del proyecto de puertos
libres del gobierno de Johnson del que
ya os hablamos aquí en visualpoli las
zonas de inversión van más allá del
reciente régimen de Puerto libre además
de
incentivos Fiscales para atraer a las
empresas también reducen la burocracia y
el prolongado proceso de planificación
lo que a menudo impide que las
inversiones se produzcan venoction
alcalde conservador de This volley uno
de los municipios beneficiados por este
plan y luego A ver os hago una pregunta
cuál es el problema que hoy por hoy más
preocupa en toda Europa tres dos uno
Exacto la energía o mejor dicho el coste
de la energía
[Música]
debido a la invasión ilegal de Ucrania
por parte de Putin y el uso de la
energía como arma fortalecer nuestra
seguridad energética es una prioridad
absoluta Jacob richmoke ministro de
energía del Reino Unido Pues bien aquí
el gobierno detrás lo tiene muy claro el
Reino Unido Tiene que conseguir una
fuente de energía abundante y al mismo
tiempo barata y la pregunta es cómo
esperan conseguirla Pues bien Además de
mantener los planes nucleares del
anterior administración y el gobierno
también ha anunciado el fin de la
moratoria sobre el fracking bajos
impuestos de regulación zonas económicas
especiales fracking no sé parece el
sueño dorado del brexit al menos Claro
está del brexit defendido por
conservadores y liberales nos parece
[Música]
hablamos de un enorme paquete de lo que
en el mundo económico se conoce como
políticas de oferta con un objetivo muy
claro que la economía británica se
despierte de una vez por todas y vuelva
a crecer lo que entradas las
circunstancias puede tener mucho sentido
Al fin y al cabo ganar competitividad
fue el principal argumento a favor del
brexit
graves nombres
pero un momento hemos comenzado Este
vídeo diciendo que el plan del gobierno
terminó con una intervención de
emergencia del Banco Central para frenar
el desplome de la libra y la pregunta es
por qué demonios los mercados se han
puesto tan nerviosos por un recorte de
impuestos parece contra intuitivo nos
parece
[Música]
pues amigos amigas la respuesta tiene
mucho que ver con la segunda parte del
plan detrás la parte que no tiene nada
que ver con margaret thatcher Y es que
junto a los recortes de impuestos
regulación el fracking todo lo demás el
gobierno también ha prometido un
fortísimo incremento del gasto público
concretamente en dos ámbitos recordáis
Cuál es la mayor preocupación de las
familias las empresas y los gobiernos de
toda Europa el coste de la energía Pues
bien Reino Unido en este caso no es una
excepción y sí vale el fracking puede
ayudar pero el problema es que no lo
hará lo suficientemente rápido así que
sabéis que ha hecho el nuevo gobierno
británico pues anunciar un precio máximo
la energía que paguen las familias y las
empresas una subvención que será pagada
por el gobierno y que como podéis ver en
pantalla supone el mayor plan de
subvención energética de todo el
continente hablamos de un gigantesco
coste que podría situarse entre los
100.000 y los 200 mil millones de libras
el objetivo del gobierno Es que la
crisis energética no afecte a la
economía nacional no castigue a las
empresas de las familias Hasta que el
país logre nuevas fuentes de suministro
barato el problema es que eso hace
sospechar que la subvención y con ella
la factura podría alargarse más de la
cuenta
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo al mismo
tiempo el Secretario de Defensa ha
confirmado lo que era un Secreto a voces
el Reino Unido elevará para el final de
esta misma década su presupuesto militar
hasta los 100.000 millones de libras al
cambio unos 110 mil millones de dólares
esto supone más que duplicar el
presupuesto actual y elevar el esfuerzo
militar hasta el 3% del pib en tan solo
8 años es decir que a partir de ahora
cada año que pase el presupuesto militar
británico crecerá generosamente lo que
evidentemente supondrá más gasto más
déficit y más deuda Pues bien ya lo
tenemos Si tenemos en cuenta los
recortes de impuestos y los incrementos
de gasto nos encontramos con algo así
como una enorme bomba fiscal que fue lo
que desató la tormenta un enorme boquete
que Durante los próximos años podría
llegar a superar los 80.000 millones de
libras cada año una enorme cantidad de
dinero adicional a sumarán Ya de por sí
importante agujero presupuestario y
quizás por eso el gobierno no presentó
su plan ante la oficina de
responsabilidad presupuestaria Para qué
para que se lo criticaran El problema es
que esta oficina que por cierto fue
puesta en marcha por el conservador
David Cameron tiene precisamente esa
función ahora bien Qué efectos puede
tener este plan para la economía
británica y es que acaso los mercados no
se fían de que en Londres pueda llegar a
pagar sus facturas Pues bien veamoslo
[Música]
el pánico
amigos amigas el plan detrás puede tener
cierto sentido Pero supone una norma
puesta donde los resultados no están
asegurados entre otras cosas porque pesa
todo existen serias dudas de que lo
anunciado sea suficiente como para
espolear a lo bestia la economía
británica Así que la presentación del
plan Tuvo tres efectos inmediatos
primero la libra se desplomó y alcanzó
su nivel más bajo frente al Dólar
segundo el rendimiento de la deuda
pública se disparó por encima de países
como Italia Grecia o España
máxima tensión en Reino Unido la libra
se hunde a mínimos de 1971 y su Bono
bate el
4,2%. y tercero con las dos
consecuencias anteriores estuvo a punto
de producirse un enorme crack financiero
con los fondos de pensiones
Por qué Pues porque como la rentabilidad
de la renta fija ha sido tan baja
Durante los últimos años estos fondos se
lanzaron a invertir más y más en
derivados sobre los tipos de interés
para intentar mejorar sus niveles de
rentabilidad y claro se desató la
tormenta de repente sus derivados
perdieron valor con lo que tuvieron que
incrementar las garantías que se exigen
para operar con estos productos lo que
los condujo a una crisis de liquidez y a
tener que vender activos a toda
velocidad y en cierto modo eso fue lo
que obligó al Banco Central a intervenir
con un plan de emergencia de 65 mil
millones de libras con esta intervención
y la promesa de presentar un plan de
estabilidad presupuestaria se calmaron
los nervios y con ello parcialmente la
libra se ha recuperado por ahora
con la intervención del Banco Central se
calmaron los nervios Pero la pregunta es
por qué se produjo tanto miedo de los
mercados Y es que acaso los inversores
no les gustan los bajos impuestos Pues
quería comida visualpolitik no cierto es
que podemos encontrar varios motivos
[Música]
en primer lugar el enorme boquete
presupuestario que supondrá este plan
será financiado básicamente con deuda y
ojo que hablamos de una cantidad que
Durante los próximos años puede llegar a
suponer más de 300.000 millones de
libras de deuda adicional y el problema
es que ya no hablamos de tipos casi cero
como ocurría hasta hace poco tiempo
ahora el rendimiento de la deuda pública
británica supera el 4%. es decir que el
país tendrá que empezar a pagar
muchísimos más intereses lo que
emborronará aún más las cuentas públicas
existe un riesgo real de que los
inversores Internacionales pierdan la
confianza en el gobierno del Reino Unido
y eso conduzca a una crisis de la libra
esterlina el mercado se pregunta cómo
vas a pagar por esto Mark doding
director de inversiones de Blue Bay
asset management segundo porque ese tema
que este plan puede alimentar aún más la
inflación y la pérdida de valor de la
libra lo que a su vez incrementaría el
coste de las importaciones y el decir
por cuenta corriente y esto podría
provocar más inflación y más caídas de
la libra y así vuelta a empezar tercero
si este escenario se produce el Banco
Central podría haberse obligado a subir
más los tipos de interés para luchar
contra la inflación y estabilizar el
precio la libra y los tipos más altos
podrían afectar al crecimiento ya que
podrían reducir la demanda de crédito y
los proyectos de inversión y eso no es
todo además elevarían aún más el coste
de la deuda del gobierno complicando
todavía más el panorama fiscal lo veis
lo que temen los mercados es algo así
como que este plan puede terminar
causando una enorme espiral de crisis
ahora bien entonces por qué demonios lo
han presentado
[Música]
Pues básicamente porque lo que el
gobierno Espera es que gracias a este
plan la economía británica se despierte
se comporte mejor que la del resto de
Europa y que entonces el crecimiento
pues diluya o evite todos estos
problemas sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta que el gobierno espera congelar
el gasto público a medio plazo los
mercados se mueven todo el tiempo es muy
importante mantener la calma y centrarse
en la estrategia a largo plazo O sí
worten canciller del tesoro y a ver qué
queréis que os diga la economía
británica probablemente necesite este
tipo de revulsivos y el problema es que
quizás el gobierno haya sido demasiado
ambicioso Al fin y al cabo conciliar la
bajada de impuestos con un fortísimo
incremento del gasto público puede no
ser la mejor idea del mundo de momento
la presión ha sido tan alta que el
gobierno ha tenido que dar marcha atrás
y congelar la reducción del tipo máximo
del impuesto de la renta al menos por
ahora y no nos engañemos de una forma u
otra quizás más progresiva este es el
camino que el brexit les obliga a seguir
si el Reino Unido quiere tener éxito
tiene que convertirse en un lugar muy
pero que muy competitivo en el mundo y
para lograrlo solo hay un camino
Pero llegó hasta aquí turno para ti qué
te parece el plan del gobierno británico
crees que el trasnomics tendrá éxito o
por contra supondrá el fin de la etapa
de los gobiernos conservadores déjanos
tu respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle a like y suscribirte si
es que aún no lo has hecho muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]